Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between MrBeast Burger
in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the US, a MrBeast Beast-style burger
comes in double and triple.
The Beast-style burger in the
UK also comes in two sizes,
the double and a triple.
It's dripping grease.
Holy sheesh!
Can you see how wet this is?
Let's weigh a triple burger now
to see whose burger is bigger.
Look how gross these
scales are, by the way.
A Beast-style triple in
the UK weighs 270 grams.
Joe: The US triple Beast-style burger
weighs 290 grams.
In the US, MrBeast Burger has one size
of crinkle-cut fries.
They come in either
unseasoned or seasoned.
In the UK, we also just
have one size of fries.
And they come as either seasoned
or as unseasoned.
Speaking of fries, the menu
offers a Chris-style burger.
Who's Chris?
His burger has fries on it,
and for this they charge
you an extra dollar,
or in the UK an extra British pound.
This got me wondering, how
many fries come on this burger,
and does that warrant
an extra dollar charge?
Let's count and find out.
One, two, three.
[fast-forwarding]
That seems reasonably generous.
27 fries on my Chris-style burger.
But what about the cost of the fries?
Let's count how many
fries come in an order.
One, two, three.
Counting that one, 92.
Let's go by volume. For an extra dollar,
you get 33 grams of fries.
An order of fries,
total is 133 grams.
How do we figure this out?
You're paying 4 pence.
3 per chip.
We had 33 grams,
equal a dollar for the Chris style, right?
How much was it?
£1.17 worth of chips in the burger.
I think technically you're paying, like,
an extra pound for this one
compared to the Beast burger.
So you actually are,
you are getting slightly
more than you pay for.
[crew laughing]
By 17p.
So if our math is correct,
it looks like on the Chris-style burger,
per gram, each fry costs 3 cents.
But if you get the
crinkle-cut fries on the side,
each fry per gram costs 4 cents.
So you're actually getting
a better deal on fries
if you get them in the Chris
burger than separately.
That's pretty nice.
That took way longer than it
should have, and I'm sorry.
Here is everything you'll find
at a MrBeast Burger in the UK.
Here's everything you can find in the US
at a MrBeast Burger.
There's a slight problem with our usual
exclusives approach to this section,
which is namely that
the UK doesn't have any.
Everything on the menu here
is also available in the US.
However, I do have a suspicion
that some of these things
might be slightly different.
So we're going to take a look.
The only food exclusive
the US has over the UK
is in the US, you can get a
MrBeast Impossible burger,
made with the Impossible beef.
That's because at the
time of recording this,
Impossible beef is not
available in the UK.
That's because it
contains a key ingredient
called soy leghemoglobin, aka heme.
According to Impossible Foods,
it's what makes some meats taste so meaty
and creates the bleeding effect.
Heme is classified as GRAS,
generally recognized as safe, in the US.
However, it does not
have regulatory approval
in the UK or the EU just yet,
although Impossible Foods do
say they're working on it.
Besides that, the only
drink you can get in the US,
can't get in the UK is Sierra Mist.
UK, consider yourself lucky.
Sierra Mist sucks.
Start down this end with the classic.
So, we have the MrBeast-style double.
Two smashed patties. There's cheese,
and then there's also pickles,
chopped onions, some
mustard, and some ketchup.
I love smash burgers,
and I wish more places did smash burgers.
You end up with these incredibly
crispy bits on the outside.
Do you see this? That's just pure flavor.
Mm. It's like beef candy. It's brilliant.
Really good.
That's pretty good. I do like this.
I don't know if I would consider
this a smash patty, though.
Tasty, juicy.
Then of course we have
the Beast-style triple,
which has the same toppings
but an extra beef patty.
The Chris style. What up,
Chris? Whoever you are.
Fries and bacon on the sandwich.
Yeah, sort of just OK.
So, this is the UK Chris-style burger.
We have bun, we have
fries with some cheese,
two beef patties,
and on the bottom, just
one piece of bacon,
and it's kind of that, like, cheap bacon.
I associate this with buffets,
particularly when you go
to an all-inclusive
resort in central Europe.
I have to try this one. It looks so good.
Mm-hmm. They didn't skimp on the fries.
This thing is dense.
So, this is the Karl's deluxe in the UK.
What they've done is, for some reason,
only flipped one of the burger buns,
and then they've kind of used that to
create a grilled-cheese effect,
which in the UK we call a cheese toastie.
But then within that you have a beef patty
with cheese on both sides
as well as some grilled onions.
The Chandler style.
There's nothing on this.
Just burgers and cheese. Like,
this food is made for 10-year-olds.
Chandler, come on, man. What's going on?
This is a very, very basic cheeseburger.
It's just bun, cheese,
meat, cheese, meat, bun.
It just feels a little bit
like when you're a little kid
and all you want is a
hamburger with bread and beef.
It's too dry. Come on,
Chandler. Live a little, man.
Get some sauce involved. Maybe
even some pickles. Who knows?
I don't know what the
Nashville tastes like
over there in the UK.
Sticking tenders in here. But this one,
crunchy.
And, of course, they also have the option
of just a regular chicken sandwich.
In a weird way, it kind of
reminds me of the McChicken,
but, like, not as flavored.
Any fast-food place,
this would be the
dollar-menu chicken sandwich.
This is $9?!
Bro!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is the Nashville hot ... [laughs]
This is so offensive to
the people of Nashville.
People of Nashville, look away now,
because the UK is about to
start another revolutionary war.
So, the problem is, in the
UK, no one really knows
what Nashville hot chicken
is supposed to look like.
So fast-food chains can
get away with serving
things like this, and
people don't know enough
to call them out on it.
What is this? Come on.
What they've done, as far as I can tell,
is just take standard chicken tenders,
and then I think they've added
maybe some of the seasoning
from the seasoned fries
and then tried to pass that
off as a hot chicken sandwich.
I'm not good with spice.
There's nothing going on there.
Zero Scovilles. That's not
Nashville, nor is it hot.
You can also just get a
chicken-tender sandwich.
I don't understand what the
difference is, particularly.
This one has pickles on it.
I just wish we could up
our chicken game in the UK.
At the moment we're not
doing the best job of it.
And unfortunately, MrBeast Burger
is not our hero when it comes to that.
So, Karl making a second
appearance on the menu.
Apparently he has a grilled cheese
that is two top buns, flipped over,
with cheese smashed in the middle of it.
This is 6 bucks.
Oh, that's really funny.
How much is a loaf of bread
and a bunch of slices of American cheese?
You can make, like, 20 of these.
This thing looks quite sad.
I think both of the buns
are supposed to be flipped.
Quite interesting aesthetic.
The cheese hasn't really melted properly,
so it's not stuck to this.
So it's just a very smooth,
shiny layer of cheese.
These are your seasoned fries.
Eh, you know.
It does give me a slight
Nando's vibe to it,
in terms of the heat level
and some of the flavor profiles as well.
Like, almost like a
peri-peri seasoning on this.
MrBeast burger also offers
something called Beast-style fries,
which comes loaded with
caramelized onions,
American cheese, pickles,
mayo, ketchup, and mustard.
This is it right here.
I don't know about this, guys.
Maybe not the most visually appealing.
However, I like the idea of
fries and pickles together.
Cheers.
I really like these.
These are really good.
And one dessert, a chocolate chip cookie.
This is a pretty good cookie.
That's not bad.
[crunching]
[thudding]
This is, like, pretty stale.
Obviously we're a bit lacking
in exclusives in the UK,
but maybe I can take some
preexisting menu items
and combine them to create
a Harry-style burger.
Trademark Harry Style.
The Chandler style, which
was the very plain one.
I'm going to take some of the
fake Nashville hot chicken,
which is not very hot at all.
Land that straight on top.
Actually, I think this will benefit from
some of the moisture on this bun,
so I'm going to keep that as well.
So, we're going for MrBeast-style fries,
'cause I quite liked the Chris
style with the fries on it.
Here goes. The Harry Styles.
You know what? We might
have done something there.
I actually don't mind the
combination of chicken and beef.
I think that kind of works.
Oh, God, what have I done?
They were too preoccupied with
whether or not they could,
they didn't stop to think about
whether or not they should.
But honestly, don't
hate it. Give it a try.
So, for my signature burger,
here's what I'm going to do.
I think this is a really good idea.
I'm excited about this.
I'm going to take a Karl's grilled cheese
and a second Karl's grilled cheese,
and mine's going to be
the Beast-style burger,
but instead of buns,
it's two grilled cheeses.
Check this out. Grilled cheese.
Double patties. Should
I put fries on it too?
Yuelei: Yeah.
Joe: Why not?
We'll make it a Chris style,
because these fries have all
the seasoning and stuff on it.
They have all the ketchup
and have all the sauces
and everything on it.
Ooh, and there's caramelized onions too.
OK, there. They got the Beast burger,
or, the Beast-style burger.
This is the Joe-style burger.
We can also call this,
I've been told I look like old MrBeast.
So this could be old-MrBeast-style burger,
or MrBeast-with-no-serotonin burger,
or I-kind-of-look-like-that-guy-
from-"Game-of-Thrones" burger.
So whatever you want to
call it, but here we go.
Oh, man, this, I'm excited about this.
Look how good this looks!
I'm an absolute genius.
This is so good.
Mm.
Oh, man!
Jimmy, put this on the menu.
Put this on the menu.
One more.
I really want to keep eating this.
One more bite. I'm sorry.
Here's a US Beast-style
double burger combo.
Over here, it will run you $15.29.
That same combo in the UK is £14.99.
Yes.
Leon's having none of it.
But what about the delivery fees?
Using the MrBeast Burger site, in the US,
the same combo with tax,
delivery fees, and tip
costs $28.72,
increasing the cost by 87.8%.
Oof!
So, if possible, you may
want to go pick up your food.
It's a similar deal here in the UK.
We checked this order on Deliveroo,
and they charge a £2.49 delivery fee
and a £2.05 service charge,
which jacks the price
up by almost a third.
One big difference worth pointing out
is the tipping culture
in the UK and the US.
It's much less common to tip in the UK
than it is in America.
In the UK, if you go to a
restaurant for some food,
it's usually common to give maybe a 10%
or a 12.5% service charge if
the service has been good.
But you can even opt out of that
if you don't want to pay it.
Particularly where delivery is concerned,
I think tipping is even
less common in the UK.
I got a notification, actually,
on my Deliveroo app the other day
to say that 6% of people in my area
have been tipping their drivers recently.
So that's six out of every 100 people
are tipping a delivery driver.
When I say that we don't have as much
of a tipping culture in the UK,
it's not that we're really stingy.
We just generally have a
much higher minimum wage
in the UK than you do in the US,
so there's less reliance on tips
to make ends meet for
service-industry staff.
We thought we'd take a look back over
the story of MrBeast Burger
to give you all some context.
It all started with a
YouTube video back in 2020,
in which MrBeast opened a
single drive-through restaurant
where the food is free,
and customers would even
get free money for visiting.
Obviously thousands of people showed up,
and the video got over 100 million views.
At the end of the video, MrBeast announced
MrBeast Burger, his chain of burgers,
which was available across
the US for delivery.
He partnered with Virtual Dining Concepts,
a platform which matches brands
with existing restaurants
and kitchens to prepare and deliver food.
By using existing kitchens,
MrBeast Burger was able to expand rapidly,
opening 300 locations in
the US in the first week,
followed by more in the UK
and Canada shortly after.
For context, it took McDonald's six years
to open 300 US locations.
You can start to see why
brands love virtual kitchens.
At the time of filming
this, there is only one
brick-and-mortar MrBeast Burger location,
recently opened in New
Jersey's American Dream mall.
At the grand opening, over
100,000 fans showed up,
some waiting in line all night.
It was a massive success,
captured by Colin and Samir,
who documented the entire day.
According to the doc,
at the grand opening,
MrBeast Burger sold 6,212 burgers
and broke the world record by three times.
Guinness World Records has asked for proof
and at the time of this recording
has not made it official.
But it hasn't all been sunshine and roses.
Pretty much anybody can apply
to become a virtual
kitchen for MrBeast Burger.
There's a form on the Virtual
Dining Concepts website
where you can tell them
which facilities you have in the kitchen.
So if you have a fryer,
a flattop, and a fridge
and you normally make fried food,
even if you just have a single location,
you can cook MrBeast Burger.
That's all it takes.
A fryer, a flattop, and a fridge.
I mean, you can buy a
deep-fryer for pretty cheap,
and I feel like you could
install a flattop on
pretty much any kitchen, and
everyone's got a fridge, so,
I feel like I could probably cook
MrBeast Burger if I wanted to.
A wide variety of restaurants
acting as virtual kitchens
has led to a slew of quality-control
issues for the chain.
The food is coming from
all types of restaurants
independent of each other,
so what you're getting may
be a bit of a crapshoot.
So we went ahead and got MrBeast Burger
from a second location.
First, the Chandler style. [grunts]
And I have to say, it
looks pretty good, right?
Very impressed.
The Chandler style from restaurant No. 2.
OK, the first thing I noticed
is the burger's not wrapped.
Is that OK?
It's bigger.
But, I mean, that's clearly different bun.
This is more of a smash patty.
How it's really almost paper-thin,
where this just looks like tiny burgers.
Chandler burger, right?
Mm, the cheese makes this one.
No. It's a different quality of meat too.
I think that this actually
is pertinent information.
This is from a restaurant in Glendale.
This was from the Buca di
Beppo's at Universal Studios.
Hot chicken sandwich.
All right, again, place
No. 1, the place we like.
It's saying it's Nashville,
but instead of doing chicken sandwiches,
they're doing chicken-tender sandwiches.
Bit of a disparity between A and B.
Mm-hmm. Not that crispy. Spicy?
That's disappointing.
There's no spice to that.
I mean, this one.
Yeah. Mm!
That, however, is much better.
Despite some of these
quality discrepancies,
MrBeast Burger shows no sign
of slowing down its growth.
Earlier this year, MrBeast
tweeted that the brand
has already shared over
$100 million of revenue
with restaurants across America.
When he says shared, it
means that not all the money
is going to MrBeast,
nor is all the money
going to the restaurants.
The restaurants will
obviously take a large cut,
but then some of the money will go
to Virtual Dining Concepts,
and I'm sure some of it is
going to MrBeast as well.
For example, one restaurant
in Dallas, Texas, claimed
it sold $7,000 worth of MrBeast
Burgers in a single day.
MrBeast actually once described
the launch of MrBeast Burger as a gamble,
but so far it's looking
like that gamble paid off.
We actually collected
today's order in-store,
and I had to kind of place the order there
by showing the guy my phone,
and he kind of tapped
it all through for me.
He was actually kind of surprised
at how much the burgers cost.
He said they looked quite expensive.
I guess it just means that he wasn't aware
of how many fees are being added on
so that either the delivery platform
or Virtual Dining Concepts can
get a fair cut of the profit.
It seems like the nutritional
stats for MrBeast Burger
are actually the same
in the US and the UK.
A Beast style with double
patties is 950 calories,
66 grams of fat, 23
grams of saturated fat,
43 grams of carbs, 41 grams of protein,
and 1,840 milligrams of sodium.
Note that is 80% of your daily sodium.
Make it a Beast-style triple,
and the calories go up to 1,160,
which is over half of
your daily allowance.
What you really have to look out for here
is the saturated fat. A Beast-style triple
contains 150% of your
daily recommended intake.
Bump it up to a Beast-style
double burger combo
with unseasoned fries
and a can of Sierra Mist.
Gives you a grand total of 1,330 calories.
Bump it up to a triple,
and you hit 1,540 calories.
Comparing the Beast-style burger
to other fast-food-chain burgers,
MrBeast, calorie-wise, lands about here.
It's pretty high up there.
But good news for Jimmy:
No one in America cares.
Leon: Next!
Harry: Next!
Fries.
Real eyes
realize real fries.